I remember again at the time of my life
when I saw this film for the first time
in theatres I bought my ticket I just
remember seeing your relationship your
marriage and I thought it was portrayed
in such a complex way and I hadn't seen
that you know and I think there's
something about the role you play in
this film that stands outside of what
the other characters are going through
just speak to me about you know how the
script came to you and what you felt
like you saw yourself in it quickly yes
I do have a story I just shared with
RINs about oh thank you about the that
scene I don't know if he knew that story
I'll share it but before that I always I
trusted Robbie Reed because I wouldn't
be here if it were not for Robbie Reed I
got my first audition for Crooklyn which
was absolutely horrible I got scared
everybody in the room and I beat myself
all the way back to Brooklyn
because I knew I wasn't going to get
that job but whatever Robbie did Thank
You Robbie thank you thank you
so I knew from that point that if I
couldn't get page 13 in the script that
it probably wouldn't be something that I
would want to do and be proud for the
rest of my life unfortunately being
african-american I got the nerve to be
picky about on top of everything how
hard it is to get a job but tell me I
got the nerve to feel like if my
children would see my work one day how
would they feel and my 18 year old and
my 12 year old daughter and my 15 year
old son who were not born before this
movies made the biggest regret I have in
this film it's when the characters
Vaughn's wife comes home and because I
wasn't a father then and I desperately
wanted to be all I could do was just rub
the top of his get away
wait let me think back there you know
you know who else gave me that criticism
it was spike spike spike said to me he
said you [ __ ] up that scene I think he
did and I said can we redo that I said
well I said what do you think because I
thought Isaiah was fantastic in that
moment when he comes in he comes with
the wires up and he goes not another the
the father
gone to his kid first I for his wife I
don't have any kids you didn't have any
kids you know buddy of Newark if I would
have been on set I would have so he
would so he had pointed that out to me
and so I'm glad you you and I don't
recognize that we kind of we missed it
right there yeah
you ever see what we had lived that
hopping skipping jumping tell me how to
stay in the relate well put my wife on a
barrister a little bit but my wife and I
just got married February of 96 pretty
much we were doing some I think Jane or
a little bit later but we just got
married and we were still trying to
figure out that scene I really
understood that power play like I'm a
pretend that I I'm a man I'm not gonna
be upset about this and we had this big
argument which was really what as big as
I think about it also Jeremiah sabe was
always trying to cut my hair to really
came treated with some some clippers or
someone to cut my hair but those two
stresses created a scene with you and I
remember the face that Lorenzo's like
dude this is not the script but you look
like you need a hug I don't know where I
went
it's like oh and another thing
since we're here and it was thank you
for holding me down there in like I
don't know what that love I don't think
that's gonna make the movie but you need
my pleasure
yeah you need help I'm gonna give you a
hug later a story but although if I made
real quick that's linen robbers okay
just than a robber
one time forever I had no career when
this when this came to me I was I was
fresh out of drama school I was working
one of my very first jobs in Toronto and
my agent at the time called me up and he
said let her Jane alderman want you to
come in to meet this guy head witcher
and he's got the story and I gave it a
read-through I breathed through it and
and he starts to talk
about it and he's just like well you
know it's it's no go you read it and let
me know what you're saying
I read this thing I could do a man I
mean where is this where is this guy's
like I wanna meet him is like I mean
really and he's like I mean I think it's
and that's like dude you don't think
anything beyond your prism as a
middle-aged white guy because you've
seen every incarnation of the more
romantic comedy from Annie Hall to
Sleepless in Seattle and everything in
between but if you're 22 and you're
black and you're going out to see a
movie with your friends you haven't seen
a movie in 1996 where somebody hasn't
died at the end right yeah yes so for
that alone I was down yes and all these
people were like starting to become
heroes of mine Isaiah was the first
person I saw on stage when I started
drama school bill was the first comic I
saw on stage and st. Louis def Comedy
Jam came through
I remember going the Menace and the
theater in Chicago was like deathly
silent and it's just like all like it
was a blessing beyond blessings to be a
part of this I would have done the
catering on me
catering was amazing with I've read the
world I'm actually curious about a mr.
Bellamy how how did Bill Bellamy come to
be in the film because uh man again talk
about a seeing somebody in a whole new
light man it was just a dog it wasn't it
was interesting because at that time I
had just bust on the scene I was I was
on fire as a stand-up comic you know I
mean I had HBO under my belt I was on
MTV my personality is more fun and you
know and Ted was like I love you and
your real life but Hollywood that's a
[ __ ] man you gotta be able to
flip that [ __ ] and alright what it was
like yeah Hollywood is a hater
and I was like I can a and in that me
and said I remember that you remember
this this conversation
he's like B people ain't gonna like you
they like you after this movie you gonna
have a problem and I had a problem women
were coming up to me you know what I
swear to God I swear the girl know if
you Hollywood a bill but both of y'all
take kids of my ass like Bernadette but
that was about six years in a row so I
was like it's a movie so so Bernadette
did you have the chemistry meet with
Bill because I feel like the two of
these characters are kind of like that
any all these things together
diametrically opposed just amazing I
don't know how we did go well all right
you know tribute to um to Ted we
actually were together on a masters a
young lady's master's piece and he was
the quietest guy on the set but he was
the only guy that had a job like after
we were all done and to walk into the
audition they didn't tell me who this
movie was or what it was about anything
and I walk in and I'm like oh my god I
know you hi you know and he it was so
that alone like kind of made me go and
breathe and then my character wasn't
even written when I auditioned she was
like okay so you need to improv and I
was like in poblet I'm gonna give you
the scene and he gave me the scene and
it was actually for late I realized it
was for Isaiah same with his wife that I
we improved and so my I had for
auditions it didn't made me audition
four times he did he and and what we
were told know was that my last audition
he he had me come in to do an African
dance oh my god you were so amazing was
involved too
I was like really it was like I came in
no shoes on African pants had my routine
down had my camera I mean my boombox and
Shawn was in the room and um a couple
other people were in the room and did my
dance music oh bring it I know it's it's
interesting because my idea for that
scene was that Sheila just sort of
impromptu stands up and starts dancing
like it wasn't meant to be good yeah
nice to just be something somebody did
at a party who's had a couple glasses of
wine so somehow Jane read the script and
put it in the breakdown like must be
able to do you know bantu dance from the
so she comes in and she can actually do
it like for real and which was not my
idea but I was like well she's so good
like we should just put her in the movie
and so the thing in the movie became
much better than it actually was
intended to be because you can actually
dance well but let me just say this
about the midgets say this quickly about
the cast what the challenge with this
kind of other than the principles the
challenge with this kind of movie
filling out the other parts is that the
movie isn't really a plot driven kind of
movie so you're not looking for the guy
to play the police chief and the guy who
plays the you know the doctor who fixes
the thing you know and the CIA director
comes into it you're not you're
basically trying to fill out some colors
that so that you can manipulate the mood
and the vibe of the thing as it's going
on because it's not really a plot driven
or even a strongly narrative piece
really right so I you get a color so I'm
like I got bill
okay what's gonna go with that color I
got a Isaiah okay well I need somebody
younger made I need Lynn you know what I
mean and you put it together like a
painter would you put one color down you
put another can you like ah let me flip
that that's how you do this kind of
movie and that's why it's such a
crapshoot
why I got so lucky with this particular
group